I gotta say congratulations new Netflix
show Alexa and Kate does it feel like a
little bit of a full-circle moment now
that you are gonna be on television and
I'm a mother of a teenager a little bit
it's a little panic moment for a second
but I'm actually really excited and the
girls are so darn cute the shows it has
a very serious message you know
undertone to it but it's a comedy but I
play a mother of a teenage girl that's
actually going through cancer how did
you then prepare for that that sounds
like a serious role same time it's a
coming-of-age story about these two
young girls embarking in high school and
even though there's cancer to it they
really try to make light and what really
is kind of the hard part of it is it
just being teenagers I mean they're
worried about what they're gonna wear to
high school and you know you know things
that we all worried about you know as
well as on top of you know
her having cancer Tiffani Thiessen
dishing on her new Netflix series Edie
was with the actress on Tuesday she and
daughter Harper were serving lunches to
children through feeding America the
nation's largest hunger relief
organization she was such an amazing
little helper she was you know giving up
the food and then putting all the fruits
and vegetables in the basket
what's the messaging that you want to
instill in her about getting back as she
grows up well I think you know I we talk
about a lot about being fortunate and
the fact that you know that not
everybody is in the same place you know
and that it makes your heart feel good
you know it's something that really like
fills your heart and fills your you know
makes you feel good and so I think today
I wanted her to see like you know these
are kids her age I do you know want to
instill the fact that we're blessed we
feel very blessed and so it's nice to
feel good about giving back a little bit
I want to talk about this children's
book speaking of kids a little bit you
and Brady are writing this what kind of
topics is it gonna cover it's a subject
that's actually pretty prominent right
now I think this day and age we're all
very much into our phones and computers
and sometimes it's nice to just unplug
and when you add an unplug I think
sometimes you realize that when you were
plugged in that you were missing kind of
the innocent moments in life usually
with your family and stuff so it's kind
of just a reminder to sometimes just put
the phone down that you try and remind
you our kids absolutely oh yes we have
many unplugged moments throughout the
day yes
[Music]